[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec orianne
mancini bonjour orient bonjour thibault
est notre invité cette semaine et
philippe dallier bonjour vous êtes
sénateur les républicains de
seine-saint-denis merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
nous allons refaire avec vous la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec au menu
un débat sans vote qui a eu lieu lundi
au parlement après les frappes du
week-end dernier en syrie
pas d'union sacrée autour du premier
ministre a critiqué par une partie de
l'opposition de droite comme de gauche
sur la pertinence de ces frappes
la loi asile et immigration en débat
cette semaine à l'assemblée nationale
loin de provoquer les seules critiques
de l'opposition
elle fait également tous et dans les
rangs de la majorité présidentielle
et puis le bras de fer se poursuit entre
l'exécutif et le parlement sur la
réforme des institutions
l'avant projet de loi a été transmis au
conseil d'état gérard larcher et
françois d'origine souhaitent tous deux
une modification du texte et on commence
cette semaine avec la syrie et le débat
qui a eu lieu au parlement après les
frappes françaises
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux jours après les frappes le
gouvernement est venu expliquer devant
l'assemblée et le sénat les raisons de
l'intervention française aux côtés des
britanniques et des américains mais loin
d'un climat d'union nationale plusieurs
voix se sont élevées dans les deux
chambres estimant que paris n'aurait pas
dû intervenir sans mandat de l'onu
le résumé des débats et s'unit fabien
rey caire damas a franchi une ligne
rouge c'est ce qu' edouard philippe a
voulu rappeler lundi aux députés avant
le débat sur la syrie une attaque
chimique avéré attribuable aux forces
armées syriennes
avec des conséquences létale
entraînerait une riposte immédiate
cela avait été dit clairement pour
autant cette intervention n'est pas le
prélude à une guerre nous n'entrons pas
dans une logique d'escaladé
car l'ennemi numéro 1 reste le
terrorisme a souligné le premier
ministre
les frappes étaient donc proportionnée
et surtout légitime pour la majorité
parlementaire il ne fait aucun doute que
les trois résolutions des nations unies
adoptée à l'unanimité la résolution 22
54 sur le processus politique en syrie
la résolution 21-18 sur l'interdiction
absolue des armes chimiques et la
résolution 21 04 sur le droit
humanitaire fondent parfaitement
l'action conduite pas d'union sacrée
pour autant les critiques les plus
sévères contre l'engagement de la france
venant du côté de la france insoumise
dans le droit international et dans
l'action internationale on peut agir que
sur la base de preuves affirmé par les
organismes qui en sont responsables
or ceux ci étaient en train de faire
leur enquête au moment où sont
intervenus les bombardements ensuite
nous avons agi sans mandat de l'onu
et je crois que c'est sans doute pour la
france le coup le plus important porté à
sa diplomatie
si l'action militaire est contestée sur
le plan légal elle ne peut l'être sur le
plan moral pour le
l'utilisation de l'armé chimique dit
quelque chose de celui qui a recours
notre réaction à cette utilisation dite
aussi quelque chose de nous au sénat
c'est jean yves le drian qui a lu la
déclaration du gouvernement l'opposition
sénatoriale a fait état de ses doutes
monsieur le ministre pensez vous qu
ajouter la guerre à la guerre puisse
faire avancer la paix c'est une
interrogation que nous avons la deuxième
réserve cancer l'efficacité de ce genre
de frappes punitives rappelant au
passage que de précédentes frappes
américaines n'ont pas empêché la
récidive
à gauche on soutient l'exécutif en
regrettant l'absence des européens
force est de constater que les frappes
montre une nouvelle fois la nécessité
d'une coordination européenne au niveau
diplomatique et militaire
et en l'espèce le compte n'y est
toujours pas au lendemain des frappes
une question demeure quel action
diplomatique pour construire la paix si
vous alliez vous étiez vous favorable à
ces frappes
écoutez je pense qu'elles étaient
justifiées à partir du moment où les
preuves étaient là je n'ai aucune raison
de douter de la parole du gouvernement
à partir du moment où les preuves
étaient apportées je pense qu'il était
temps de marquer un coup d'arrêt c'est
ce que nous aurions dû faire
effectivement en 2013 est un orateur a
rappelé il y avait des résolutions à
l'époque unanime du conseil de sécurité
aujourd'hui la russie est dans une
situation différente elle oppose son
veto mais je pense qu'il était temps
effectivement que nous essayons
d'arrêter les choses pas de garantie que
le régime de bachar el-assad ne
réutilisera pas les armes chimiques mais
on ne pouvait pas rester sans rien faire
vous dites les preuves ont été apportées
vous les avez vu vous ces preuves parce
que le gouvernement a déclaré les
détenir mais en la matière est ce qu'on
peut se contenter de mots ou de je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas vu les preuves d'abord
ce que vous appelez voir les preuves
mais je n'ai pas de raison de douter de
la parole du premier ministre il ya une
réunion dimanche matin à matignon à
laquelle j'ai assisté en ce que les
preuves étaient là et donc il fallait le
giron est ce que la france ne devrait
pas s'interdire toute intervention en
pays étranger sans mandat de l'onu
mais on est dans une situation très
particulière les russes
un jeu très ambitieux et ils bloquent
effectivement la prise de la prise de
décision à l'onu donc effectivement soit
on considère qu'à partir de là il n'y a
plus rien à faire et détourne le regard
soit effectivement on essaie de faire
bouger les choses
je crois que les russes il faut regarder
la réaction qui a été la leur
effectivement ils ont beaucoup critiqué
ils ont dit s'attendre de choses mais
les frappes en lieu et il n'y a pas eu
de d'enchaînements de d'escaladé
derrière je pense qu'il était peut-être
aussi temps d'envoyer un message à
vladimir poutine
maintenant la bonne question c'est celle
de la praye parce que les frappes ont eu
lieu
maintenant il faut voir comment on peut
essayer de sortir de la situation de
blocage dans laquelle on est on a
entendu un des voix dissonantes à une
sorte de votre groupe l'est républicain
au sénat notamment entre bruno
retailleau et gérard longuet est ce que
vous regrettez dont je le regrette pas
on peut avoir des appréciations
différentes
c'est vrai que c'est assez rare mais je
suis ne suis pas tout à fait sur la
longueur d'onde de bruno retailleau je
pense que gérard longuet je suis sur sa
longueur d'onde
je pense qu'il fallait agir la question
est là mais bruno retailleau l'a rappelé
également on viens de l'entendre la
question et c'est effectivement celle de
la suite est il sans oublier d'ailleurs
qu' on a en iran en iran n'a en syrie
une présence de l'iran qui relativement
nombreuse on nous parle de 20 mille
hommes aux frontières d'israël et il y a
un très gros risque d'embrasement donc
la question est de savoir que font les
américains 30 pas dit tout et le
contraire est ce qu'il va évacuer ses
militaires ce qui serait à mon avis
quelque chose à serait regrettable
comment est ce que on arrive à régler le
problème sans que tout cela dégénère
parce que le risque à mon avis est très
important on va passer flip d'aller à la
noix asile et immigration en débat cette
semaine à l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trop répressif pour les uns trop laxiste
pour les autres la loi asile et
immigration n'en finit pas de diviser à
l'assemblée nationale des débats l'eau
et houleux qui ont également laissé
apparaître des divisions au sein de la
république en marche
rabhi caf dès le début de l'examen du
texte les républicains sont montés au
front déposant une motion de renvoi en
commission et une motion de rejet
préalable
ils dénoncent un texte laxiste et plein
notamment pour l'instauration de quotas
pour limiter l'immigration
nous souhaitons que chaque année le
parlement vous mes chers collègues fixes
en fonction de l'intérêt national des
plafonds d'accueil d'étrangers par
catégorie de motifs de ses joues les
immigrationnistes pensent que
l'immigration est toujours en soi une
chance pour la france
ils ne comprennent pas le choc de
désintégration produit par l'immigration
massive
les deux motions sont rejetés mais la
gauche s'inquiète d'une surenchère
répressive
alors que pour elle ce texte va
détériorer l'accueil des migrants
on voit bien après le discours nauséeux
de notre collègue l'arrivée que ces
derniers pendant le débat au un rôle
celui de jouer à l'idiot utile du
maquereau nice met à faire passer une
loi extrême pour noah équilibrer votre
argument station nous semble aussi
indigne et dangereuse que le projet de
loi lui-même ce projet de loi qui traite
l'étranger en délinquant l'enfant en
adulte le malade en un poster et le
demandeur d'asile en fraudeurs à la
république en marche une quinzaine de
députés dénoncent également ce texte
qu'il juge trop répressif face aux
critiques
gérard collomb plaide l'urgence à agir
face à la crise migratoire que vit selon
lui l'europe
cette crise nous le savons a bousculé
nos structures de protection contribué à
faire monter les craintes fait basculer
un grand nombre de pays de notre
continent dans un populisme agressif et
xénophobe
plus de mille amendements ont été
déposés sur ce texte dont près de 200
par la majorité
pédalier comment jugez-vous ce texte
vous est ce que gérard collomb a trouvé
finalement le bon équilibre entre
humains et et fermeté d'abord je pense
qu'on peut rappeler que nous avons et ça
ne date pas d'hier
un vrai problème de maîtrise des flux
migratoires dans ce pays c'est tellement
vrai que l'on nous dit qu'on aurait
aujourd'hui 300 mille clandestins sur le
territoire français j'ai tendance à
considérer que ça pouvoir être quand
même nettement supérieur à ce chiffre
donc nous avons un problème de maîtrise
de l'immigration nous avons une crise au
moyen-orient et dans certains pays
africains qui fait que beaucoup
effectivement et c'est de venir en
europe certains effectivement au titre
de l'asile politique mais beaucoup
également comme réfugiés économiques
donc nous avons besoin effectivement de
redéfinir une politique et l'idée de
fixer des quotas et que le parlement
fixe des quotas me semble une bonne idée
nous avons également besoin en matière
de demande d'asile d'accélérer les
procédures ce qu'effectivement il ça
fait des années d'ailleurs qu'au sénat
mes collègues dans leurs rapports
budgétaires chaque année pointe
effectivement le manque de moyens d'un
côté des procédures qui sont extrêmement
longues et on aboutit à quoi mais quand
les gens sont déboutés du droit d'asile
ils sont là depuis 18 mois 24 mois ils
sont parfois dans la nature et il n'y a
pas de reconduites effective ou
d'éloignement comme on dit aujourd'hui
donc oui il y a des problèmes à régler
il faut les régler donc le texte il ya
des points effectivement positif je
pense que tout ce qui va dans le sens du
raccourcissement du traitement des
dossiers est une bonne chose
maintenant il faut que les moyens
suivent parce que on sait que
effectivement les organismes chargés
d'examiner les dossiers sont surchargés
et après il ya la question l'éloignement
et sa passe est extrêmement compliqué ce
que la ligne adoptée par votre parti
pendant les débats on l'a entendu d'un
sujet très ferme n'a pas rendu service
finalement à la majorité parce que d'une
certaine façon en vous livrant une forme
de surenchère est ce que ne fait pas
apparaître le texte du gouvernement
comme justement équilibré où tu es nous
sommes dans l'opposition et nous sommes
là pour poser des questions et les
ministres doivent répondre je fais
allusion à l'incident en séance à
l'assemblée nationale où madame goût
roman scène c'est la triste que je
connais bien centriste s'est tout d'un
coup énervé a piqué une colère parce que
les députés lui posait des questions et
qu'il souhaitait savoir si louis
il y aurait des vagues de régularisation
et parlementaires en droit de savoir les
français ont le droit de savoir
nous le savons par exemple j'ai été
surpris de voir que gérard collomb le
découvrait que beaucoup et ça je
chiffrent en dizaines de milliers de
personnes et souvent des familles sont
hébergées à l'hôtel depuis parfois des
mois et même des années
ils ce sont des cas qui n'ont finalement
jamais été traité des gens qui sont en
situation irrégulière et vous savez
comment les appels on les appelle des
personnes a droit un complet ce qui est
quand même assez étonnant quoi comme si
effectivement on attendait le dernier
papier pour pouvoir régulariser le nom
la situation c'est pas ça c'est qu'on a
des gens qui sont en situation
irrégulière et depuis des mois des
années ce la situation perdure tout ça
n'est pas acceptable il faut
effectivement qu'un mobile et l'état
tranche et l'opposition est tout à fait
fondée à poser des questions c'est toi
va arriver au sénat est ce que vous
allez la réécrire pour y intégrer votre
vos propositions et notamment la
révision du droit du sol prônée par
laurent wauquiez
bien évidemment que le sénat se saisira
du texte de l'assemblée nationale et je
ne doute pas que la commission des lois
avec françois noël buffet et qui sera
une autre rapporteur
demandera le texte sur le droit du sol
là aussi il faut regarder les choses
telles qu'elles sont regarder ce qui se
passe à mayotte par exemple est-ce qu'on
peut laisser la situation née à la
maternité de mayotte c'est la plus
grande maternité d'europe c'est
effectivement ce qui se passe il ya des
femmes qui prennent le bateau au risque
d'ailleurs de leur vie et qui viennent
effectivement côté français pour
accoucher avec tout ce qui en découle
derrière il ya des problèmes aux
antilles il ya des problèmes en guyane
mais il ya aussi des problèmes en france
je pense que nous sommes tout à fait
légitime a reposé la question je ne dis
pas que c'est une question simple à
trancher mais en tous les cas il faut
que le débat ait lieu
très bien on en vient à notre troisième
thème philippe dallier la réforme
constitutionnelle
le débat a été relancé cette semaine en
cause l'avant projet de loi transmis par
le gouvernement au conseil d'état révélé
par la presse il contient des surprises
sur la révision de la procédure
parlementaire des surprises pas vraiment
du goût du président des présidents des
deux chambres gérard larcher en
particulier a tonné contre des mesures
qui viseraient un abaissement des
pouvoirs du parlement explications samia
déchire une attaque sans précédent
contre les pouvoirs du parlement
pour le président du sénat le projet de
réforme constitutionnelle ne passera pas
en l'état la révision constitutionnelle
ne pourra pas se faire sur l'abaissement
des pouvoirs du parlement - remontée que
gérard larcher
françois de rugy espère lui aussi
modifié le texte à l'assemblée nationale
sommes dans l'optique de rajouter
d'enrichir le compléter le texte du
gouvernement
parmi les points de friction de
nouvelles règles du jeu établies sans
l'ordre du jour des deux assemblées
le gouvernement pourrait imposer
l'examen d'un texte
à l'agenda des deux chambres au motif
qu'ils seraient prioritaires y compris
pendant le temps réservée à l'initiative
parlementaire
l'encadrement du droit d'amendement fait
aussi débat seuls les amendements en
lien direct avec un texte serait
dorénavant jugé recevable une atteinte
au droit d'amendement pour de nombreux
parlementaires le gouvernement veut
aussi raccourcir la navette
parlementaire
en cas d'échec d'une commission mixte
paritaire a trouvé un compromis entre
les deux
a semblé plus de nouvelles lectures dans
chaque chambre mai dernier mot à
l'assemblée nationale au passage
l'exécutif pourrait introduire des
amendements avant adoption définitive
sans qu'ils aient été adopté au sénat
le rôle du sénat en tant que relecteur
des textes en tant que poil à gratter de
l'assemblée nationale sur certains
dossiers
et bien ce rôle là on va en grande
partie disparaître le gouvernement ne
pourra pas passer en force
il lui faudra une majorité des trois
cinquièmes au parlement pour aller au
bout de son projet philippe dallier le
président du sénat gérard larcher a
envoyé un long courrier au président de
la république se disant préoccupé
savez-vous s'il a obtenu une réponse je
ne sais pas effectivement s'il a obtenu
une réponse
ce que je sais ce que je pense c'est que
le jir a marché parfaitement fondé à
protester contre la méthode parce que
cela fait des mois effectivement qu'il
négocie qui discutent comme le président
de l'assemblée nationale d'ailleurs avec
le gouvernement alors quand c'est pour
découvrir que ce qui s'est dit n'a pas
été respecté ça pose quand même un
problème
puis elle problème de fond c'est que
depuis cinquante-huit ça sera la
première réforme constitutionnelle qui
va viser donc pas rééquilibrer le
pouvoir entre le parlement et l'exécutif
mais qui va affaiblir le parlement et ça
c'est absolument insupportable
est ce que le sénat sera le grand
perdant de cette réforme si elle est
mise en route mais la messe n'est pas
dite
croyez bien que nous allons nous battre
et nous allons et ce qui également
essayé de convaincre l'opinion publique
et c'est extrêmement difficile parce que
aujourd'hui la seule chose que les
français regardent ces on a dit on va
réduire le nombre de parlementaires à
c'est super on l'a moins d'élus tous
allés formidablement mieux mais le fond
du débat il n'est pas là d'abord parce
qu'on nous dit que la guerre de l'ombre
parlementaire c'est pas pour faire des
économies
on nous dit le parlement aura plus de
pouvoir mais en matière de contrôle et
c'est le sentiment que nous avons c'est
que le gouvernement nous prend pour des
empêcheurs de tourner en rond
il souhaiterait que affaiblir notre
pouvoir en matière de d'écriture de la
loi et nous contenait
le contrôle même ça c'est inacceptable
et je pense que la bataille va être rude
à la lecture de cet avant projet de loi
qui a été transmis au conseil d'état est
ce que vous dites que l'exécutif cherche
à porter atteinte aux bicamérisme mais à
tous les cas une partie des 1000 des
dispositions qui sont proposés bon
affaiblir le sénat et sa borne ou que
c'est absolument inacceptable
il faut que nous restions dans l'
équilibre qui est l'équilibré actuel de
la vème république
entre les deux chambres et équilibre
également vis-à-vis de l'exécutif
et là on voit bien que le sénat dans les
deux cas sera perdant et ça c'est
inacceptable
le président du groupe la république en
marche à l'assemblée richard ferrand a
proposé que l'élection des sénateurs se
fasse à la proportionnelle intégrale à
l'échelle des régions votre réaction
cette proposition est un scandale absolu
non pas en soi bien que je considère que
c'est une ânerie
cela éloignerait encore plus les élus du
terrain mais parce qu'il présente ça
comme un chantage et c'est ça qu'il
tient acceptable on a le président du
groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée qui dit
au sénat si vous n'adoptez pas ce qui
est sur la table
en plus on changera le mode d'élection
des sénateurs pour passer à la
proportionnelle au niveau régional
qu'est ce que c'est que ces méthodes et
on a une ministre madame gouraud qui
dans l'hémicycle s'offusque parce que
les parlementaires soit des quais des
réponses aux questions qu'il pose mais
qu'est ce qui est en train de se décider
voilà c'est vrai pour les élus locaux on
sent leur ras-le-bol qui monte
on est jugé comme responsable de tous
les maux de la terre en matière de dette
publique les collectivités c'est 10 % de
la dette publique donc il faudrait
arrêter de vous faire porter le chapeau
et au parlement on voudrait
effectivement nous cantonner et et le
gouvernement dit on veut aller plus vite
plus vite plus vite mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette vision de la démocratie
et on termine ce tour d'horizon de
l'actualité parlementaire avec le vote
de la réforme de la sncf il a eu lieu
mardi après-midi à l'assemblée le texte
a été adopté par 4 154 voix contre 81
outre la majorité une grande partie des
républicains mais aussi les élus d y
agir ont voté pour tandis que les trois
groupes de gauche nouvelle gauche
communiste et insoumis ont voté contre
29 députés se sont abstenus clip d'ail
et le texte va arriver au sénat le 29
mai le soutiendrez vous en tous les cas
très probable que je
vote à la fin parce qu'effectivement je
pense que cela va nous bon sens d'abord
à l'ouverture à la concurrence qui est
une réalité à des échéances qui sont des
sciences de moyen terme
et puis à la situation de l'entreprise
on ne peut pas continuer comme ça il ya
une dette abyssale
alors certes les politiques en sont
responsables parce que les
investissements massifs dans le tgv on
les a faits portés à la sncf et la
question de la dette et une vraie
question le président de la république
est resté assez flou en disant qu' au
moment où la sncf sera transparent se
transformer en société anonyme on
reprendra une partie de la bête combien
je pense que il faut réformer le système
de toute façon il m'est plus viable et
donc il y avait urgence à prendre des
décisions
on va maintenant passer fait d'allier à
la partie politique de cette émission
avec notre partenaire du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour cela nous accueillons sur ce
plateau ginger difficile d'allier un
jour on va reparler un peu d'immigration
puisque laurent wauquiez à proposé cette
semaine un référendum sur le sujet
est-ce que vous soutenez cette idée
j'hésite hésitant et oui vous savez
c'est un peu comme sur la réforme des
institutions
je le disais tout à l'heure voilà on dit
on va rivière de parlementaire et on ne
parle que de ça sur l'immigration
commencerez formuler les questions je
pense que le parlement un rôle à jouer
dans ce pays surtout sur des sujets qui
sont extrêmement sensibles et moi je
serais plutôt favorable à ce que le
parlement discute mais de tous les
sujets effectivement de la mise en place
de quotas qu'on puisse discuter du droit
du sol parce que ça n'est pas un sujet
tabou mais ouvrons le débat mais on rend
le laurent wauquiez justement à proposer
une question un peu floue un seul on
sait selon ses critiques est ce que vous
souhaitez que la france se dote de loi
qui réduisent au minimum l'immigration
bon ça c'est qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous en dites justement de cette
formulation ce que j'en dis c'est que je
pense que ça fait un moment que ça dure
nous ne sommes plus en capacité
d'intégrer correctement tous ceux que
nous accueillons quand on parle des
migrants suite à la crise au
moyen-orient enfin regarder la situation
avec des gens qui dorment dans la rue on
ne sait pas régler les problèmes
voilà même si ça va un peu mieux sur le
front de l'emploi on sait bien que ce
pays n'a plus la capacité d'accueillir
autant de monde donc il faut poser les
problèmes et trouver la meilleure
solution
est ce que est ce qu'avec cette
proposition laurent wauquiez donne
l'impression de courir derrière le front
national sont écoutés à arrêter de nous
renvoyer sans cesse le front de sueur et
la figure parce que cela voudrait dire
que parce que les le pen père fille
maintenant est la nièce bientôt par le
sujet depuis des années
salah interdirait à tous les autres d'en
parler donc je pense qu'au contraire la
force de ne pas en parler ça fait monter
le front national parce que les français
ont le sentiment que nous n'avons pas le
courage de poser les véritables débats
et de prendre les solutions qu'il faudra
prendre sur le plan de la grogne sociale
on a vu qu'elle se poursuit emmanuel
macron a été sifflé lors de son
déplacement dans les vosges
cette semaine est ce que c'est une
alerte sérieuse selon vous qui doit qui
doit prendre en compte si le président
de la république multiplie les
déplacements et les interviews à la
télévision c'est certainement parce
qu'on sent du cotec de viser que la
grogne monte dans le pays
il pense que le départ de la grogne
c'est probablement la sphère de la csg
qui à mon avis a été une erreur
catastrophique pour le gouvernement il
aurait mieux valu comme nous le
proposions l'année dernière toucher à la
tva plutôt que de toucher notamment
retraite et aux petites retraites
donc on s'agite un peu inutilement au
public dans tous les sens et puis il ya
beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de sujets sur
la table il ya une multiplication des
francs quand même est-ce que vous croyez
en terme un peu barbare à la convergence
des luttes comme d'harmonie je n'y crois
pas parce que je pense que et d'ailleurs
on le voit un peu dans les sondages que
ça soit sur la sncf est encore plus
peut-être sur les le blocage des facs
avec des situations absolument
inadmissible et je me réjouis
effectivement de l'évacuation de tolbiac
cette nuit quand on voit les images des
dégradations de cette bande
d'hurluberlus là qui veulent rejouer mai
68 et qui crée des centaines de milliers
d'euros de dégâts si ce n'est pas plus
je pense que ça les français ne le
supporte pas parce qu'au bout du compte
ce sont eux qui payent la facture alors
tobia qui a été évacuée il ya un autre
sujet qui est celui de notre dame des
landes
est-ce que selon vous l'état est
suffisamment efficace sur les vacations
la zad a coûté à je pense que ce qui a
été fait à tolbiac le gouvernement
aurait mieux fait de le faire en amont
sur notre dame des landes
parce que les promesses qui avaient été
faites d'évacuation rapide et négocier
on voit bien ce que cela donne mais là
aussi les français considèrent que c'est
insupportable
et en plus ce que je regrette le
gouvernement abandonnait le projet
d'aéroport
donc on aurait pu penser que tous ces
gens là allait libérer le terrain mais
pas du tout il en arrive de plus en plus
c'est parfois même d'ailleurs en europe
et on voit bien que
ils sont là pour casser du flic et du
gendarme c'est absolument inacceptable
il faut que l'autorité de l'état
s'affirme alors vous êtes élu de 510
vous avez longtemps été maire des
pavillons sous bois est ce que vous
pensez que le plan borloo qu'on annonce
depuis quelques jours
48 millions d'euros nous dit on billy à
1 milliard milliards excusez moi puisse
changer le quotidien des habitants de
votre département qui est le plus pauvre
de france
j'ai d'abord redire que et ça ne date
pas d'hier pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
mauvaise polémique et regarder ce qui se
passe on en parle peut d'ailleurs parce
que l'actualité est chargée
il ya eu en seine-saint-denis aux abords
d'établissements scolaires à saint à
stains aux abords du lycée utrillo des
incidents d'une extrême gravité avec des
lycéens attaqué à coups de marteau avec
des jets de cocktails qui contenait de
la cl on a dans la banlieue de toulouse
au mirail effectivement un quartier qui
s'embrase à nouveau
on a et on ne connaissait pas ça il ya
une vingtaine d'années on a des
phénomènes de bandes qui luttent pour
effectivement aka père et des
territoires
et on a aussi le trafic de drogue qui
essayent effectivement de conserver
puisque la solution et les ans la
situation désespérée comme l'a dit par
exemple stéphane gatignon qui a été que
stéphane guillon en est lui assez
d'avoir l'impression d'écoper la mer
avec un dé à coudre je le comprends
parfaitement et ce qui m'amène à dire
que j'attends de voir d'abord le détail
du plan borloo mais avec borloo on a
bien réussi ce qui concerne l an russe
qui concerne l urbanisme et logement
meyel tout le reste il y a effectivement
l'éducation il ya un l'emploi à la
formation mais il faut aussi et
peut-être il faut commencer par là que
l'état que la république revienne dans
ces quartiers il faut voir le nombre de
fonctionnaires de police dans le
commissariat en seine saint denis mais
c'est à cent kilomètres des besoins au
tribunal de bobigny on manque de
magistrats au manque de greffiers il
faut que la république s'impose et il y
a plus qu'urgence alors j'attends de
voir ce que borloo va dire et je pense
qu'il dira des choses intéressantes
parce qu'il connaît bien ces sujets mais
nous avons besoin de revoir revenir la
république et le pubis et le terrain
accaparé par ceux qui veulent la mort de
la république ça c'est une certitude
c'est la principale émission merci jean
si beaucoup philippe dallier vous avoir
fait avec nous cette semaine politique
et parlementaire
pas de parlement hebdo durant les deux
prochaines semaines pour cause de
vacances parlementaires
on se retrouve donc le 11 mai pour un
prochain numéro très bonne journée à
tous
[Musique]